Reading her book.
It was very effecting how you were in high school when nine 11
happened. And you just like were like, Oh my gosh,
like the entire perception of Muslim Americans has been changed
by this event now certainly they're different in many respects. I mean,
everything is different,
but I will say that the closest analog I can think of to
the fact that now Asian Americans are perceived as responsible for the virus
was in your own experience as a Muslim American post nine 11.
[Inaudible]. Yeah, no, I, I, um, it's
, it is devastating to watch as people who are doing nothing, but trying to protect themselves and their families from what we're all trying to protect ourselves. And our families from are now being hit with the added burden of discrimination, simply as a function of what they look like and, and where their families come from. And yeah, I remember being a junior in high school when nine 11 happened. And I, you know,
I, I remember it was the beginning of the school year. Right. So, um,
you're still excited about, about school starting and you're just getting into your groove. And for, for me, you know, it was the first time that I went from being
a
Brown guy with a funny name, to being a very particular kind of Brown guy with a very particular kind of funny name. And then all of a sudden, right. Everybody
sorta knew all of the epithets. They knew all of the stereotypes, you know
, for our family in particular, my little brother who's eight years younger than I am. His name is
[inaudible].
Oh my gosh. Wait,
if you were a junior in high school that makes you like 16 years old,
he's like eight. He was eight. Yeah. Yeah, no,
that would have been brutal, brutal. I'm sure.
At some point he even thought about like,
maybe I should like go by another name. Did he like adopted another nickname.
To his credit? My parents asked them, they said, you know, you,
you can go by Sam, we'll just start calling you Sam. He said, no,
my name is Osama. That's what you named me. And that's my name?
And I'm proud of it. I, you know, it was just, it was a,
it was a sort of a moment of just being like, you know, that's, uh,
it takes a lot for an eight year old. Who's getting bullied left and right.
My brother is also kind of like your brother. He's just one of those really,
really good, nice people and his response when he'd get bullied for his name.
And of course it's still happens.
Wasn't to lash out wasn't to hit back his response almost always was just this
like extremely, emotionally mature response, which was, you know,
when you say that it really hurts my feelings and it just diffuses everything,
right. People are just that when they hear that, they're like, Oh, I'm,
I'm sorry, man. Like, I didn't, I didn't mean to hurt your feelings.
And it's just so, I mean, emotionally mature beyond, beyond his years, he said,
you know, I'm not, I'm not ashamed of who I am and what my name is.
And I'm proud of my name it in Arabic. It means lion hearted. And you know,
in fact my parents, uh, my name, my full name is Abdullah man.
It's 11 letters long and nobody can say it.
So I became Abdul before I started preschool. Uh, because that was, you know,
1989 and Paula Abdul was a thing and Kareem Abdul-Jabbar was a thing.
And then eight years later they had my little brother and they're like,
you know, we've got to give them an easier name. So let's just do,
Sam was on the front and on the back. And so like,
my parents are over two on boys' names. Um, but yeah, it was,
it went from all of a sudden being different to being a very particular kind of
different.
And you knew exactly what the stereotypes were going to be and how it was going
to hit you. And so, you know,
my heart goes out to Asian American folks in our communities who have to bear
this, and I'm just deeply sorry. And I'll tell you this whenever.
And if ever I see it, I want to call it out.
And I think all of us should make that commitment to call it out because it's
wrong, it's dangerous and it's hurtful.
And it's something we need to always constantly be doing work to root out in our
societies.
No. When I think about the people who are affected for whatever reason,
I just keep thinking about this Chinese family.
I met in Iowa where they just ran like the local Chinese buffet.
And they were very, very sweet people.
And right now I'm sure every restaurant in that town is closed,
but I have this sinking feeling that even after restaurants reopen that,
that family's business is going to be worse than it
was. And then that's going to play out across Chinatowns around the country,
around, uh, you know, those like ethnic food marts that I personally love.
Whenever I see like an Asian food market, you probably say way,
like probably like, what do you see? Like certain,
certain ethnic food markets we just run in and there's like, Ooh,
where did you get like four or five things from your childhood that remind you
of that effect? Like, I,
I have this sinking feeling that all of those businesses are going to suffer
because people are just going to not want to go to that restaurant that
Chinatown, that community, that food market.
And I think it's going to persist.
Do you have any tips for folks who are like new to this?
You know, I, um, you know, I think, I think certainly, um,
people of color in our country have, have experienced this for a long time.
And also, you know,
it's important to call out that COVID-19 has had a disproportionate impact on
black Americans and native Americans.
And so we're seeing structural racism play out, um, in a number of ways.
Yeah. That's happening right in Michigan. Right.
I think I just saw the stat where African-Americans are at 13% of the state of
Michigan, but 40% of the deaths so far.
That's right. And so, you know, I don't know that,
that I can share anything that other folks haven't already experienced or
thought through. But what I will say is, number one,
we all have a choice about where and how we spend our money.
And so if you've got an ethnic Rocher in your community who you think is going
to be in trouble because of the, I hate to say it,
the xenophobia and the discrimination, uh, in a community,
make sure you go spend your buck out there, right. That's,
that's a simple thing that all of us can do. Number two, I think, you know,
the impact of this is so much more disproportionate on young
people because it frames the way that they think about themselves.
And I think one of the most important things that we can do is make sure that
we're constantly empowering young people who face discrimination on a
daily basis. And, um, reminding them that they're beautiful,
that they're meaningful,
that they matter that they have power and that we are proud of them, right.
Because that's where they get their own sense of their pride and their value and
their sense of belonging. And then number three,
that I am my life used to respond to a lot of this by, by hitting back.
And I found that just over time, that, that.
Just so you know, I don't know people, I can see you Abdul right now,
but a duel seems like a pugnacious type, uh, terms of like,
he, he like played football, I think, in high school and like, uh that's right.
Yeah. Generally like, certainly I can very easily see,
like if someone gave you in high school, you'd be like, all right, let's see.
I hate to say.
And it's sometimes my first reaction. Um, but it's never my best reaction.
Well, I think, I think part of it's just like where you are, you know,
in terms of your maturation stage, like,
because I can imagine in high school you would just hit back immediately.
No college probably say the same, but I mean,
at this point you're like a dad,
like you been like the head of the department of health, the city of Detroit,
you, you pretty much have to learn to have a very thick skin. At some point.
You start to appreciate is that people who engage in this form of behavior,
oftentimes they do it because they've given themselves licensed to try and take
away your humanity. And I think, you know,
if I learned anything in my little brother, is that in that response,
when he would say, you know, that hurts my feelings, what he was doing was very,
very clearly asserting his humanity. People have feelings, right?
And if you're able to, to look at somebody and say, you know what you said,
really hurt my feelings.
It forces a certain empathy because all of us have had our feelings hurt.
And I just think that there is a space to ask,
why are you saying what you're saying?
And how can I show you that what you're saying,
actually it defiles you just like it just like you think it defiles me.
And if we can grapple with forcing people to
come to terms with the mutual shared humanity
that all of us have in this moment, I think we're all the better for it. Right.
And then the other thing is one of the points that my mom used to always make is
that no, at some point you can only control you and you can ask yourself,
what did you do in that moment to bring out the best in someone?
And obviously when someone's being racist and discriminatory,
they're not their best. And you know, some would say, well, you know what?
I don't owe them anything. And that's true. You don't.
But I think there is always an opportunity to ask how do I bring my best in a
situation? And how do I pull out?
Even the shred of what's what's good in that person that's left. Like,
all right.
So I've got an opportunity to engage someone who's not being their best.
Can I bring my best to bring out their best? Because if you can do that, right,
that's the kind of person who truly changes things that constant ask.
It's a hard thing to do. And certainly if you don't, if you choose not to do it,
no harm, no foul. I don't blame you, but there is a real opportunity there.
And that opportunity is worth taking, I think.